[موسيقى]
خلافات علي الخامنائي قد لا تكون على نفسي
قدري اهميه السلطه
في ايران يمكن ان يخلف عليها
السلطان لم يحصل عليه مبارك الاسلاميه
مدنيه ولكنها في الواقع الحارس الثوري هو
الذي يتخذ القرارات الاستراتيجيه في
النظام ويتخذ القرارات السياسيه كما يوزع
ثروات ايران كما يشاء
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وين شهد قاسم سليمان ماني
الذي استمتع به بعض الشهره او الشعبيه ليس
فقط
شخصيه كارزماتيه اخرى من صفوف الحرس
الثوري ولكن اعتقد بانهم من
الارجحاول ان يكون هنالك خليفه
ويحتفظ
النظام من اجل تقليدي التكلفه التغيرات
السياسيه وبالمناسبات ومن اجل
فولجرام كل شيء ايضا هو اخطاء كثيره 16
ايران في المفضل لحرس الثوري ان يكون
هنالك قائد مدني تحمل مسؤوليتي كل الاخطاء
الحاصله وبعد ذلك ياتي لحراسه الثوري
ليفخر
بالانتصارات التي سيحققها
[موسيقى]